what is the greatest national security
threat to the United States the chaos in
the Middle East there's no doubt about
it okay it all started with the Iraq
invasion Governor O'Malley I believe
that nuclear Iran remains the biggest
threat along with the spread of ISIL
climate change of course makes cascading
threats even worse since I Clinton the
greatest national security threat I
think it has to be continuing threat
from the spread of nuclear weapons
nuclear material that can fall into the
wrong hands I know the terrorists are
constantly seeking it and that's why we
have to stay vigilant but also United
around the world to prevent that senator
Sanders great isn't a scientific
community is telling us if we do not
address the global crisis of climate
change transform our energy system away
from fossil fuel to sustainable energy
the planet that we're going to be
leaving our kids and our grandchildren
may well not be habitable that is in a
tonight senator Webb our greatest
long-term strategic challenges our
relations with China our greatest
day-to-day threat is cyber warfare
against this country our greatest
military operational threat is resolving
these situations in the Middle East